bonjour à toutes et tous la période que
nous traversons est évidemment difficile
éprouvante
parce que nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreux à être directement ou
indirectement touchés par cette épidémie
parce que nous nous inquiétons pour nos
proches qui sont en première ligne dans
les hôpitaux ou les cabinets de la
médecine de ville pour soigner les
malades et puis tout simplement parce
que le confinement dans lequel nous
sommes placés touche à ce que nous avons
de plus précieux et sans doute de plus
intime
c'est à dire notre relation les liens
qui nous unissent à c est ce que nous
aimons mais cette crise doit être
justement l'occasion de réfléchir au
monde que nous voulons laisser à nos
enfants car rien ne sera jamais plus
comme avant
nos relations sociales nos relations
économiques l'organisation de la
démocratie la gouvernance mondiale
tout est à repenser tout est à
reconstruire et il est de notre devoir à
nous démocrates de participer à cette
reconstruction
vous le savez lors de notre université
de rentrée à guidel nous avons lancé
l'initiative universités 133 qui vise à
identifier la particularité du regard
des démocrates des centristes sur les
grands enjeux contemporains
nous avons confié un groupe
d'universitaires historiens et
politistes juristes philosophes le soin
d'interroger notre histoire nos
responsables nationaux et nos adhérents
sur quatre questions fondamentales
démocratie citoyenneté laïcité europe et
relations internationales économie et
développement durable et société et
solidarité nous avons besoin de votre
avis et de vos idées sur ces quatre
questions fondamentales à la lumière de
la crise que nous traversons pour les
exprimer rien de plus simple il vous
suffit de vous connecter sur notre plate
forme de consultation agorad m point fr
je répète agorad m point fr l'a dit
déposer votre contribution
votre message
après la crise viendra le temps de la
reconstruction
il est notre responsabilité nous
démocrates d'y participer
alors je vous invite à ce que nous
puissions nous retrouver sur agorad m
agora donne point fr à très bientôt